[Musique]
les bienvenus au centre case de la
montagne nous sommes situés à saint
bernard
depuis l'an 2000 et c'est un club très
familial qui accueille les enfants à
partir de 3 ans
[Musique]
au bout
cette ferme et castres revit depuis
quelques semaines les cavaliers ont
retrouvé leurs chevaux qui étaient
isolés pendant tout le confinement un
plaisir retrouvé pour salomé ses copines
et j'aime bien être avec mes amis j'aime
bien bossé les poneys les sortir les
faire voter les poneys c'est un être
divin et il est gentil doux et surtout
robin tu quand tu fais du galop vin
c'est bien tu balle l'air libre du temps
partiel a été nécessaire pour les
salariés qui devait malgré tout
s'occuper des 45 chevaux tout en restant
motivé le même type de travail tous les
matins nettoyage il faut bien il faut
bien les
nourrir et puis en même temps donc les
box et les uns les autres les entretiens
ont pas silo à grains ça me coûte 2800
euros
le clan pour un mois voilà donc ça m'a
permis d'avoir 1800 euros pour avoir un
mode granulés c'était la bienvenue du
département aimé mes élèves ont continué
certains de payer d'autres ne pouvaient
pas payer parce que eux aussi ont une
des problèmes financiers
ajoutez à cela l'entretien et les
salaires c'est principalement les
adhérents qui finance habituellement
cette activité à travers une subvention
exceptionnelle de 40 euros par animal
ce bol d'air de trésorerie était donc
nécessaire pour survivre département
devait réagir pour apporter son soutien
à la filière équine
alors on a missionné la v2 r c'est une
association
d'élevage des équidés et la chambre
d'agriculture pour gérer le dispositif
qui a été mis en place
le pied à l'étrier c'est maintenant
plein d'espoir que la filière se relance
[Musique]
marquer que là pour jouer août on n'a
pas beaucoup d'élèves qui vont partir en
métropole
ils vont rester sur la réunion donc du
coup on a à des stages comme chaque
année mais ça se remplit beaucoup parce
que il ya moins de départs en vacances
hors département yasar et puis nous on a
un projet d'améliorer le club en mettant
un toit avec du photovoltaïque sur la
carrière
à voir la joie de vie des 160
participants de ce club ce coup de pouce
de 44 1700 euros était salutaire pour
les 1120 cheveau bénéficiaires dans
l'île
nous